[Musique]
regardez bien ces images
non elle ne vous choque pas car ce
paysage vous le connaissez bien c'est
celui de votre pique nique dominical
oui la forêt salle ne vous choque plus
vous avez l'habitude est aussi votre
part de responsabilité
bien sûr vous ne laissez jamais rien aux
pieds les arbres
ce sont les autres pour ses enfants de
la classe d'histoire et de géographie de
mademoiselle bouquet du lycée de talence
ce n'est pas la même chose
ces images les chocs ces enfants vont
pour vous coller des affiches et
peut-être vous donner une petite leçon
[Musique]
bien sûr ce geste est symbolique ces
enfants ont pris conscience d'un grand
problème la conservation de la nature
[Musique]
eh bien depuis plusieurs années je suis
préoccupé par la nécessité d'abord de
donner une formation morale à nos élèves
et ensuite je dois dire que plus
récemment j'ai pris conscience de la
gravité du problème que pose la
protection de la nature notre
civilisation
je pense que si on veut sauver quelque
chose il faut commencer par les élèves
vont commencer par leur apprendre à
respecter souscrire ces fauves là jean
rostand disait si chaque enfant
comprenez et connaissez la nature
l'homme pourrait être enfin ici les
élèves de mademoiselle bouquet soigne
les vieux chênes
[Musique]
ceci ne doit pas être un rêve mais
l'effort que vous ferez grâce à ces
enfants qui ont compris un grand
problème est qu'ils ne veulent pas que
le prochain printemps soit silencieux
[Musique]